you're a magician do you ever like do
tricks with your dogs oh yeah I've
actually used the minutes of Gracie so
she's a chihuahua she used to be really
really chubby and you can do anything
with her put her anywhere and she'll
just stay it's there she'll take a
little puppy Buddha statue I don't have
a picture of her video but I instead of
using a rabbit I pulled Gracie out of
that top hat in front of the kids like
another reading stuff no not for the
book to her but on property brothers
every now and that kids would be like
the funny thing too is see you later I
want to pull him out of it
the plan I think - is I'll do magic
tricks for the dogs and they've some
dogs freaked out because they don't
understand where I can show you one you
want to see if you see if I can get a
reaction to your little puppy he's not
interested in the tree here well he just
ate like 5 feet right here you go oh wow
yum yum watch this here we go ready
where'd it go what pull it out of the
puppy here he doesn't know what it like
I actually think this is it's actually
the same when Jonathan med for human
consumption as well okay
[Applause]
that's not white beautiful thing that is
that's best Jonathan and drew thing
that's creepy Jonathan Jonathan think
okay okay I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my YouTube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this